- A lot of people don't spend
two weeks consuming my stuff
so they see a headline
or two and they're like,
"Yo hustle this or hustle that."
(peaceful piano notes)
I always talk about sleeping a lot.
I always talk about, like if you love it,
you know look what anybody here
and definitely anybody
listening or watching,
if you really love it, like for real.
Not like you're kind of saying it
'cause you're trying to
get through your life.
If you really love it,
it truly isn't feel like work.
Like school felt like work
and that was only like
nine to three with tons
of breaks in between
and that was devastating.
You know?
My audiobook, reading it.
I'm only halfway through, that's work.
- [Interviewer] You looked
like you were in hell.
I was watching the video today.
- It's not easy for me, man.
Like I don't like it.
And so like I know what work,
I know what not liking it feels like
and what work feels like.
Being an entrepreneur for
me, running businesses,
putting out content, doing my thing,
does not feel like work.
I mean look.
I talk a lot about hard work.
There's not a whole lot
of content coming from me
on the weekends.
I take four, five, six, seven
weeks of vacation a year.
Like what I'm doing is I'm
maximizing my 15 hours a day
during the week but I, yeah.
My only kryptonite is
the health of my family.
From the day I left school in May of 1998
to this moment, I've
always been the operating
partner of a business.
Everyday.
- [Interviewer] I think
that gets blown by.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] People
get stuck on the noise.
- Look, look.
I think people should and that's life.
People get caught up and sizzle over steak
everyday of the week.
But I like that because I
think I'm kind of playing
to that a little bit.
I think I'm forcing that narrative
'cause I'm a fan of the reveal.
Like aha, I told you.
Like I like being underestimated.
I prefer it.
I'm more comfortable in it and so,
you know, yeah.
And ultimately I also don't care.
Like the truth is gonna speak.
Like you're not gonna build
a billion dollar by accident business.
Like either you're good
enough or you're not
and so I know how this plays out.
Other than the health and
wellbeing of myself and my family,
there's no shot I don't achieve
enormous business success
in my life.
I'm too good at it.
- [Interviewer] It's interesting though,
I mean 'cause you say that you don't care
and I know you don't and that
reptile part of your brain
I very much admire.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But then I've also gone on Reddit
'cause I've spent fucking
two weeks doing this.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And seeing you.
- Interact with people,
do it all the time.
- [Interviewer] Slate said
that something like 80%
of your tweets are fucking replies.
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Which,
that is a staggering stat.
- I have empathy for people
that don't see it my way.
I'm so thankful that
somebody consumes my content
that even if they say I'm a charlatan
and a Snake Oil Salesman,
I wanna show the respect
of them engaging in my content to reply
and have the conversation
'cause I'm intrigued
by the insight of, I'm in
tune with how I'm perceived
by engaging with people
that started off by thinking
I was a shit.
And I'm also empathetic.
I'm a pretty funny character in a snippet.
Two Weeks Full Consumption you gotta read,
28 seconds in a stream,
in the right moment,
I'm not super fun for a lot of people.
Plus, I'm also a suffocater.
I will suffocate shit.
The reason I think I'm helping people is
I'm suffocating bullshit
like no, this is not
the President's fault.
No, this is not your bosses' fault.
This is, you're insecure.
And you're insecure
probably 'cause your mom's
a piece of shit.
So we need to talk about that.
That's not conversation that
people are excited about.
Like, hey great news,
your boss isn't a dick.
Your mom's fucked up.
Let's talk about it.
Em, not as interesting.
It's much more fun to
say my boss is a dick.
But that's not what's happening.
So, let's have that conversation.
I'm willing to go there because
I think I'll win in the end.
I think I'm bringing value.
And I take people's
attention very seriously.
And I will never take it
for granted and it manifests
in me being a kind guy.
It also manifests in
me engaging with things
that hurt my feelings.
I'm super pumped that
my fourth grade friends
and my sixth grade
teachers and people coming
out of the wood works,
I am not that thoughtful about it.
I am tripling down on who I am.
I'm as super charismatic and
nice as shit to everybody
long before I thought that
anybody would even know
who I was, 'cause that's my
DNA and how I was raised.
So, you know it's funny, I
didn't grab you that way.
I get it.
And it runs through my mind.
I'm very aware that there's eyes on me.
And now it's gotten
completely bat shit crazy.
Like it's super weird.
But the best part is bro,
it's exhausting playing a character.
I have the most energy,
but I would never be able
to win that game 'cause I
would have a vulnerability.
- [Interviewer] Well, it comes out.
It's going to come out.
- You will never win.
All this shit does, is
exposes who you actually are.
And so, I just like people.
I just like em.
Plus, I like looking 'cause
I like to learn from it.
Like I don't know, it's
a good place for me.
The world becoming more
people centric and at scale,
that became a really
good thing for me, man.
Like that really worked out for me.
My impact is extraordinary
and I'm in a totally different place.
And I'm really impacting people.
And that's really cool.
Like you know, I don't
think people understand
what it feels like when
people send you emails
about being homeless and now being better.
And I really go into emotional places
with my entrepreneur talk.
Like I go there.
You know, I go there.
And so I'm enjoying myself tremendously.
You know what, I'm very aware.
Like that coming back and
shaking your hand in that moment
is a good thing.
That people will understand that.
I almost am having one
macro version of that
with myself right now.
I know that doing all these
right things are gonna lead
to some pretty extraordinary.
I mean, I genuinely believe
that everybody on earth
will know who I am.
I genuinely believe that.
- [Interviewer] Stay true
to you, that's what I hope.
- Brother, you have to
understand, it's binary.
There's just no event, even
like, I know there's no event.
I mean, I guess I could hit my head,
maybe a boulder.
Like I have some real, I don't
meditate 'cause I'm scared
to change who I am.
- [Interviewer] I was
gonna ask you about that.
But I ran out of time.
You don't meditate.
- I don't.
That person has not gotten
you to fricking meditate.
- Nope.
- [Interviewer] But Tony, he.
- No, I feel in a very, very good place.
And I really am excited
about one core thing.
The fact that I've become
cool to a lot of young people
is a big deal.
Because now I've crossed a
chasm into a different place
where I'm able to redefine characteristics
of coolness that excite me.
If I can achieve making self
awareness, and patience,
and gratitude, and empathy
cool characteristics,
I'm an alpha male.
Might have a real fucking at bat, man.
And honestly, I have that audacity.
(peaceful orchestra music)